um
so i have just a quick little update i
haven't have an update
i saw the title of this and i was like
oh no so let's just play it
we all need to get the four minutes the
rest of it's just the typical stuff
this is our friend uh earl this is
dayton hyperdova
um it's late at night right now
um i'm trying to avoid having a camera
on around my family at all when they're
awake or when they can hear me how about
just don't do it
no no very important most part even
though probably a lot of my videos are
in day time
they're usually during some sort of
panic
situation where i have the camera on and
i'm venting that's usually why i have it
on a day like oh and the video before
this was him saying somebody contacted
him
about he thinks it was christina ricci
or dr phil
also so this guy wears all of these
dresses and [ __ ] that he wants to
eventually sell in his store
right so you buy stuff at like you buy
these shitty little dresses at
ross and then you put them on your flaky
gross psoriasis skin
right and then he's gonna resell them to
people in downtown dayton ohio yeah
this all sounds well they call downtown
dayton ohio the the rome of america
that's true d-town it's the best [ __ ]
dope
right at hours at all because i'm always
risking them seeing me on camera
overhearing me and
usually i don't think they hear me but
that doesn't always happen and that's
why i'm like
trying to avoid that during daylight or
like the daytime
so basically imagine thinking you're
interesting dayton imagine this
imagine you making video after video
thinking
i have to get this information out
people are waiting for this
i'm well the only reason i'm actually
doing this tonight as far as turning the
camera on isn't
for any other specific reason that i can
really think of right now other than
someone um
someone contacted me
a text message um yesterday i responded
and of course i posted a video last
night about sending the text message so
i took
like a screenshot of it from my ipad
so um too many details replied to them
and they talked to me a little bit today
on text messaging
but um considering that this was fourth
of july uh
kind of part of the fourth of july
weekend or whatever
um they couldn't talk to me over the
phone so i assume that's just because
they're
out on vacation or something but there's
someone from
now their phone numbers the new york
city
area code new york city you're telling
me
well no i get it dayton you know a lot
of these rich hollywood producer types
very patriotic they are and they would
definitely like yeah these these
these new york city hasidic uh producer
types would definitely
be taking off on fourth of july of
course and holding that uh
holding that holiday sacred right yeah
so i know that much and i know their
name but i'm not gonna say it on here
um i'll say it you should say it it's a
fake name anyway
so nobody cares what it's you're right
you're right you're right
it's rz because i don't know some guy
named ira shecklestein
it's like you know it's gonna be some
kind of dog whistly name
yeah his name um was uh ezra
sheckle googleberg like jesus christ
area code so i know that much or
emmanuel rodriguez whatever and i know
their name but i'm not gonna say it on
here
i'll say the letters are z because i
don't know
so close that'll just be that as a
reference to them
rz whoever they are like that person
they texted me from their new york city
area code uh phone number
he's falling for trickery that were to
work 20 years ago
right i mean you're right you're right
you wouldn't have a 2-1-2 number only
important rich new york city types can
get their hands on one of those
coveted numbers or someone with a google
voice or literally
just go to google and i wanted to one
two three and they'll give it to you
hang on
you're going laying around i don't know
anybody
unless it's associated to christina
region anyway
they didn't specify christina ricci but
they said a celebrity of some
kind has uh he really thinks he has like
a connection to he does
he met her once in dayton but that's he
paid for the special package i still
i i still want to know what the [ __ ]
happened to christina richie's a lot of
hands
hand sanitizer after that by the way
after she met him but like what happened
she [ __ ] on benjamin
but like how do you go from being
christina richie
to doing the dayton car convention
that's that's very good we're not
talking about like oh yeah you know
comic-con's coming to tampa and you're
like all right well that's a
that's a nice town you know no of course
we're talking
the dayton ohio horror convention
i asked them to reach out to me yes
so i mean essentially as a leeway or a
whatever whatever the word would be for
the
middle person in that situation to talk
about
what i'm going through uh at home and
everything
so um i'm assuming it's i mean i could
be wrong i don't know if they didn't
clear they did not clarify that it's
christina richie so i don't know
but that's the only person i know who
you don't know
her you don't know you know
dude but like
you don't know her that's frustrating of
course
yeah you know it's like they're friends
you know it's like um
i got a i got a call from los angeles
and the only one i know from los angeles
is chris evans
so it's like it's got to be him you
don't know chris evans well i mean i met
him at a comic-con one time
did he even make eye contact with you he
was on the panel
oh so he didn't even see you were in the
crowd but he's i'm he looked at you for
a second he's gonna call and help
invest in my boutique why do you have
all this rope and tape
i'm gonna i'm opening up a motorcycle
shop in dayton ohio oh are you really
yeah he's gonna help me he's gonna be my
partner
you know knows how to contact me it
would be for me also if you could get me
in touch with uh i need a daytime tv
host too steve wilkos
i got it i got him for you steve wilkins
the bouncer to jerry springer who got
his own show that's steve wilco's yeah
okay yeah chris i was letting people
know they didn't know who was chris oh
god
i think they know you guys have to know
something dude you would be amazed how
many people that are younger
to turn around that fast yeah man it
really is gone already
he's not on tv anymore dude deter i see
i don't know because i don't watch
that unemployment because that's like
unemployment after no it really is
there's an onion there's a block of
unemployment television
um mori rory all that [ __ ] it's like
you're either unemployed or you're
homesick from school it's the only time
you watch these television shows the
queen of that was ricky lake and then
she just left
ricky lake yeah ricky lake blew up uh
who's the
there was they just came and went but i
thought steve wilcox was like the new
guy
because he would always be like oh no
apparently steve locos is still on but
he's played like on the wb
oh he got syndicated to like the wp
networks
i would love that gig though that's got
to be the oh of course
he talks sit down when he talks with you
hey talk to me big guy
what's going on man and then like two
seconds later you're gonna respect your
parents and then you're like and cuz oh
he retired okay
so how do you retire from that it's not
like
he retired they gave him a gold one i
fell right give him a gold watch
would you not hang on to that would you
not cling to of course jerry springer is
did for
i think this is the last year of his
show i think he did it for how many
years i would have been the jay leno of
daytime television i would have been
destroying all of my competition and
just consolidating my power
alright so here it comes here comes the
important stuff i'm posting this video
because they asked me
to um say
the words new boot
goofing
[Laughter]
that's amazing
and when they tell you to say code word
you don't just
he's not you're supposed to work the
code word in naturally you're not just
supposed to just say
they told me to say a code word the
password secret password he's not very
smart
so um he's a very stupid he's not a
smart he's not a smart lady
[Music]
say the words new
boot goofing so i'm not sure what that's
about
is it to clarify goofing
goofing he's never been to la sapiria by
lorena that's the problem
quick video payments three i got a
layaway three payments
what was that i'm just good or say it in
the video
this jump he does from outside of the
store
uh [ __ ] so then he feels stupid saying
and now he now what this is what he says
there's a code and i'm being like the
worst at code because i just said it
acknowledging that it's code so i have
no idea if i was supposed to say that
no that's not what you were supposed to
do you've already failed your audition
earlier yeah seriously that way or not
so i'm doing the worst at this by
acknowledging outright that that's code
word
but um and then he uploaded it
i don't know anyway if i'm making a
mistake doing that way i feel bad so i
don't know if that's the right way to do
it
i'm pretty naive on this subject so
imagine being this
terrible at everything in life right
yeah it really is
it really is bad like imagine having a
son and it turns out like this and
you're like
man you couldn't just be one of those
weird anime like hentai porn guys
that would have been way better way more
acceptable you would have found a better
community just hang out with anime black
dudes and play smash brothers yeah you
know
you can't you couldn't have [ __ ]
bought some bell delphine [ __ ]
bathwater and called it a day
i have no idea it could just be a troll
for all i know i have no idea
it could be no it is are you sure it's
not dr phil's people
i have no idea and at this point in my
life it's like whatever you know
um so i i was like i was going through
that one
this is just like why would they want me
to use those words i keep going over my
if it sounds like something that doesn't
sound like anything to me but those
words
so anyway i'm just getting video
acknowledging and i would assume that it
has something to do with clarifying the
person in the video
so i don't know anyway um just mumbles
like he's just a squirrely little guy
that mumbles to himself non-stop
now i'm not gonna play the rest of the
video because the rest of the video he
goes back to is typical they beat me in
this house
and the be serious yeah watch he does
this whole thing and then once he's done
and and there's no
air conditioning in this house they have
like one ac unit in the living room
that's where my older brother is
sleeping right now i am not entering
that room because he's an alcoholic mess
who beats me
in front of anybody so he is
she doesn't want to wait he doesn't want
to wake the [ __ ] okay
what a hoarder too and you're right man
you know i was thinking that the
boutique
is terrible but if he is flaking and
bleeding
can you resell he's trying on all of
these clothes
yeah he of course seems great course he
wears it yeah of course he wears it
just suitcases well thank you dayton